so mr speaker yesterday's apology lasted
for as long as the prime minister
thought necessary to be clipped for the
news
but once
once the cameras were off
once the cameras were off the prime
minister went to see his backbenchers
and he was back to blaming everyone else
he even said that the archbishop of
canterbury had not been critical enough
of putin
in fact the archbishop called putin's
war
an act of great evil and the church of
england has led the way in providing
refuge to those fleeing
would the prime minister like to take
this opportunity to apologize for
slandering the archbishop of the church
of england
[Applause]
mr speaker i i think the
the the right honorable gentleman uh i i
was i was slightly taken aback to be uh
for the gov sorry mr speaker i was
slightly taken aback for the government
to be criticized over the uh policy that
we have uh devised to uh end the end the
deaths at sea in the channel as a result
of cruel criminal gangs i i was
surprised uh to be that we were attacked
for that and actually mr speaker it
turns out that that policy do you know
who proposed that policy uh first of all
in 2004 it was david blunkett uh mr
speaker
who said it was a twenty-first yes it
was and you'll remember a 21st century
solution to the problems of illegal
asylum seeking and immigration uh he
should stick with he's a corbyn easter
he's a corbyn eastern a smart islington
suit that's the truth
i think you'll find mr corbin doesn't
have the whip but i think that's a no
then
pathetic he never takes responsibility
for his words or action
they were all there the prime minister
also accused the bbc of not being
critical enough of putin
would the prime minister
but the prime minister have the guts to
say that
to the face of clive myery
least doucet and steve rosenberg who
have all risked their lives day in day
out on the front line in russia and
ukraine uncovering putin's barbarism
[Applause]
if the right honorable gentleman wants
to uh join the conservative party and
come and listen to uh what uh the
meetings of the uh conservative he's
welcome to do it uh but though
as i say i think he's a corbynist for
the listington suit but i said nothing
of the kind
and i have the highest admiration uh as
a as a journalist and a former
journalist for what journalists do
i think they do an outstanding they do
an outstanding i mean i think he should
withdraw what he just said it has
absolutely absolutely
absolutely no basis or foundation in
truth
here's dharma
that's how he operates a merely mouthed
apology when the cameras roll
a vicious attack on those who tell the
truth as soon as the cameras are off
slander decent people in a private room
let the slander spread without the
backbone to repeat it in public
how can the prime minister claim to be a
patriot when he deliberately attacks and
degrades the institutions of our great
country
sorry mr speaker
mr speaker not not premise just just a
second
i want to hear the prime minister's
answers i expect it both ways
prime minister
[Music]
uh mr speaker
an indication of the depths to which
he's willing to sing that he accuses me
he accuses me
he accuses me of producing journalists
what he says what he says is completely
without any foundation whatever
i did not attack the bbc last night for
their coverage of ukraine he must be out
of his tiny mind mr speaker
i said i said no such thing and there
are people behind who will testify to
that he is completely wrong mr speaker
that that is that is the limit that is
the limit of his a willingness to ask
sensible questions today uh we are
getting on this government is getting on
with the serious problems that require
attention fixing our energy uh supply
issues i'm making and by the way i'm
doing the damage of the labour
government that didn't invest in nuclear
power for 13 years
we're the nuclear power station every
year standing up to putin mr speaker uh
when uh he would have elected a putin
apologist that's what he wanted to do
and he campaigned to do that mr speaker
and fixing our economy with record
numbers of people now in work
productivity back above what it was
more than half a million people back on
the payroll than there were before the
pandemic began mr speaker that is as a
result of the decisions the tough calls
this government has make
we get on with the job while they
flip-flop around like beach flanders on
the beach mr speaker
[Applause]